[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2016 alors en couple avec Vincent
miclet Ayem Nour donne naissance à Evin
leur petit garçon hier sur les réseaux
sociaux son ex-mari a posté un message
qui a fait l'effet d'une bombe lundi
matin après avoir déposé mon fils à
l'école sa maman aime l'a enlevé de
l'école sans mon consentement il affirme
alors avoir porté plainte et fait part
de son inquiétude nous n'avons aucune
nouvelle de Evin et là ce que nous a
révélé Vincent miclet aujourd'hui c'est
que Ayem aurait voilà été chercher son
fils qui est scolarisé au Maroc à
Marrakech précisément dans une école
américaine sans le prévenir et que du
coup elle aurait pris le petit avec sa
maman et que aujourd'hui il n'aurait plu
de nouvelles donc il aurait déposé
plainte et il a fait une espèce de
d'alerte enlèvement sur Instagram j'ai
obtenu la garde une décision de justice
française je suis épuisée ça fait quatre
jours que je ne dors pas que je passe ma
vie dans les tribunaux et dans les
commissariats là il a porté plainte
avant-hier pour enlèvement d'enfant il
enlève mon enfant étant donné que j'ai
la garde et là ce matin je découvre
qu'il a également porté plainte pour que
moi je ne puisse pas quitter le
territoire marocain alors où je vous
parle je suis bloqué au Maroc avec mon
fils parce qu'il ne souhaite pas
restituer le passeport de mon fils il a
fait une alerte publique sur les réseaux
sociaux je ne peux même pas sortir de ma
chambre parce que je j'ai des gens qui
me prennent en photo à mon insu
c'est un cauchemar je vis un cauchemar
je suis enfermée dans ma chambre
là avec le petit depuis qu'il a fait ce
pas sur Instagram je sais pour lui
c'était la seule façon de récupérer son
fils c'est vrai qu'en plus ayem est allé
étaler au Maroc avec sa mère et que ça a
toujours été très compliqué entre lui et
la maman d'Ayem c'est d'ailleurs il a
expliqué que c'était l'une des raisons
de leur rupture ça fait cinq ans que ça
dure les procédures et qui me fait des
menaces et qui me fait du chantage et de
la pression psychologique et de
l'harcèlement psychologique d'ailleurs
je me demande encore même comment je me
suis pas encore suicidée avec tout ce
qui me fait depuis des années et je n'en
peux plus et je m'efforce de de garder
la face publiquement à chaque fois et de
faire comme si de rien n'était de ne pas
répondre je suis épuisée je n'ai besoin
de la peine et de la pitié de personne
je voudrais juste qu'on me laisse
rentrer tranquillement avec mon fils je
me battrai jusqu'au bout et je ne
repartirai pas sans mon fils ça c'est
une certitude merci à toutes l'équipe
merci à Cyril merci à tout le monde
c'était marié Vincent miclet
mais non non ils étaient pas du tout
mariés ils ont vécu ensemble pendant
trois ans et d'accord ils ont eu
alors elle s'en est pris donc également
à Yem au blogueur et à ceux qui disent
que cette histoire est une histoire
d'argent justement elle va vous répondre
pour tous les petits idiots les petits
blogueurs de base étage les petits
bouffons qui a sur Instagram et Twitter
parce que vraiment je vous le dis vous
êtes des beaux fonds sur les réseaux
sociaux sachez que ce n'est pas une
question d'argent
donc vraiment faut arrêter avec ça parce
que c'est fatiguant vraiment vous êtes
fatigant sur les réseaux sociaux je peux
plus vous voir on a eu des preuves qu'il
a eu des contacts avec des blogueurs
pour la dénigrer sur Internet et en fait
ce qui ressort de cette histoire c'est
que Vincent Miquet donc c'est un homme
qui a très bien réussi sa vie
professionnelle qui a un homme d'affaire
à succès mais qui est fasciné par la
chose qu'il n'a jamais eu c'est la
notoriété et quand il a rencontré im
c'était une énorme star et enfin elle
est toujours très connu IAM et il était
fasciné par ça et on a l'impression
qu'il veut encore faire partie de ce
monde qui n'a jamais digéré leur
séparation mais non mais et de dévoiler
là aussi il fait le visage de son fils
qu'elle n'a jamais dévoilé elle a
toujours mis un point d'honneur à ne pas
dévoiler le visage de son fils je trouve
ça pas très correct et pas très classe
il y a à peu près 30 minutes
Vincent a fait la demande
de récupérer l'enfant
ils ont refusé sa demande ils ont pris
en considération la décision de justice
en disant qui me laissait l'enfant
puisque l'enfant c'est moi qui en avait
la garde
en revanche en ce qui concerne le
passeport la restitution du passeport de
mon enfance
ils m'ont demandé d'aller faire d'autres
démarches parce que ce n'était pas de
leur ressort donc Vincent continue de
garder le passeport et ne souhaite pas
rendre le passeport puisque le procureur
lui a demandé rendre le passeport il a
Vincent a refusé et ils m'ont dit
d'aller faire d'autres démarches auprès
de de la France du consulat français
pour qu'ils puissent me rendre le
passeport
qui a été déposée pour enlèvement et
caduque et que maintenant la garde est
officiellement reconnue au Maroc comme
elle était en France Ayem elle va
pouvoir revenir là ou pas alors ben non
parce que pour l'instant
il y a pas la restitution du passeport
de l'enfant il va falloir sans doute
considérer que le premier passeport
n'est pas restitué donc en refaire un
autre et là comme elle le dit c'est pas
de l'affaire du tribunal où elle était
là mais sans doute d'une autre
juridiction marocaine
[Musique]
pas de
de limite au bout de
la reste à manger je vais être allumé
[Musique]
dans la
si je te mens et encore et encore
ton dans le
dos je souffle le
[Musique]
mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va Matthieu tu t'en sors
vraiment I Love You
était le premier à passer
[Applaudissements]
que le vivre ensemble il est encore un
avenir en France je sais pas moi je me
suis inscrit un club de tir
est-ce que je suis pour les armes non
est-ce que je suis pour la violence non
on pourrait prendre ça au deuxième degré
et se dire c'est une grosse connerie
parce que le fait d'aller s'inscrire à
un club de tir ne te donne pas le droit
d'aller flinguer tous les gens qui vous
en la rue déjà au départ mais c'est une
façon de répondre il y a tellement de
choses qui se disent sur les difficultés
du vivre ensemble on se dit ok bon parce
que vous voulez dire quand même c'est je
m'inscris un club de tir parce qu'on
sait jamais je peux en avoir besoin un
jour pour me défendre c'est ce que vous
voulez dire ou ces ensemble non mais
c'est possible dans ces cas-là on va
aller jusqu'au fond du raisonnement et
on se dit jamais je ferai de mal à qui
que ce soit parce que j'ai jamais fait
j'ai jamais tué personne mais il est
vraiment une réalité si quelqu'un
passait le mur de chez moi pour faire du
mal à ma femme et mes enfants je sais
que dans les minutes qui suivraient ma
vie basculerait que je finir en prison
mais qui passerait plus jamais le mur
pas par revenir sur l'histoire de la
petite fille qui a eu un problème avec
un titre qui passait et que le père a
chopé et il lui en a mis deux et alors
plein de gens se disent on aurait eu on
aurait peut-être fait pire
la police elle fait ce qu'elle peut elle
est pas là partout mais on peut pas
faire justice soi-même mais attention
j'ai jamais dit j'étais là pour faire la
justice moi-même mais j'ai dit ne passez
pas le mur de chez moi pour faire du mal
au mien c'est tout exactement
on te pose la question du rôle des
médias en général dans cette histoire
est-ce que par pourquoi est-ce que il a
raison d'un fait divers à la télé est-ce
que ça veut dire que ça peut arriver à
chaque fois de rue c'est la question je
me pose je crois pas mais c'est toujours
sous-jacent il existe une espèce
d'ambiance malsaine qui fait que
d'ailleurs sur cette sur cet exemple on
m'a posé des questions pendant deux
heures j'ai parlé de plein de choses et
on a retenu que 10 secondes donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un certain esprit qui est
toujours là j'ai le souvenir de gens qui
ont manifesté pour faire libérer un
vieux monsieur qui a eu peur qui a
parfois les gendarmes et qui disait il y
a des gens chez moi venez vite j'ai des
gens chez moi venez vite bon il a pas
tué les deux personnes qui étaient là
ils les a blessés il s'est quand même
fait de la cabane est-ce qu'il avait
raison est-ce qu'il avait tort peut-être
pas mais il a eu peur pendant un moment
et il a téléphoné il y a des
enregistrements de la gendarmerie donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ces cas-là on
se fait tuer on se fait mettre en
morceaux moi si je dois être obligé
malheureusement de faire mal à quelqu'un
parce que je pourrai pas faire autrement
pour défendre ma famille je le ferai tu
as déjà fait ma vie sera foutu le
lendemain mais ça sera comme ça il y a
un tel sentiment d'impuissance par
rapport à des situations quand je dis
l'impuissance c'est de se dire mais
c'est pas juste c'est pas normal on
devrait pas vivre comme ça on devrait
pas avoir ces angoisses là on devrait
tous ce qui a été cité tout à l'heure
que ce soit de la petite Lola ou le père
qui a récupéré le type qui montait pour
aller revoir sa fille d'une manière
honteuse il y a un moment est-ce que
c'est un monde normal il y a toujours eu
des tortues il y a toujours eu des
criminels mais c'était pas aussi
banalisé que maintenant c'est effrayant
tu as réagi sur Jean-Luc Lahaye on le
rappelle le chanteur est mis en examen
pour des soupçons de viol sur deux
adolescentes jusqu'au mois de mai
dernier il dormait derrière les barreaux
d'ailleurs il y a quelques conneries qui
ont été faites mais on peut pas trop lui
jeter le caillou parce que il paraît que
au
calme-toi calme-toi parce que c'est
dans les mêmes les mêmes folies
sexuelles non voilà
quand vous utilisez le terme des
poulettes qui venaient parce que c'était
gentil c'est pas du tout méprisant ça va
peut-être pas plaire au féminisme mais
bon il avait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes femmes autour de lui
et quand je dis beaucoup
c'était une autre époque Daniel
excessivement ici on est pas sensible
Daniel je te le dis ouais
la mère de Jonathan Daval Martine Henri
publie un livre dans lequel elle relate
la vérité sur son fils sa vérité le
meurtre le procès la prison la vie en
tant que mère de Jonathan Daval et c'est
incroyable merci Martine Henri d'être
ici merci d'être avec nous vous
entendiez bien avec Alexia au début on
est bien il se marie en 2015 et c'est là
que les choses vont doucement sont venus
de l'extérieur vous voulez que leur
couple Madeleine ou pas du tout tu peux
un petit peu mais pas voilà c'est pas
plus inquiétant Martine vous vous
souvenez de de ce fameux jour ce 28
octobre 2017 bien entendu ah oui
vous souvenez de quoi qu'est-ce qui vous
vit en tête en premier
les gendarmes étaient tous dans la
maison et puis que j'avais pas le droit
de passer j'avais pas le droit de voir
vous l'avez appris comment
ben par mon mari qui passait il allait
au boulot et puis il a passé dans la rue
il m'a appelé il savait pas ce qui se
passait parce qu'il a pas pu passer j'ai
appelé
notre fils Stéphanie elle a été voir et
puis c'est là qu'elle nous a dit oui il
y a plein de gendarmes c'est tout est
barré pas une seule fois vous n'imaginez
que Jonathan puisse être impliqué dans
la disparition de sa femme pas du tout
une seule fois j'ai non pour moi c'était
pas lui
votre fils est-ce que vous le sentez
est-ce que vous sentez un moment que ça
ça tourne et que on sent que Jonathan a
quelque chose à voir avec cette
disparition non je m'en suis pas aperçue
mais Jonathan me disait souvent tu sais
maman c'est toujours le mari le
meurtrier et ils vont un jour ils vont
venir me chercher puis moi je disais non
c'est pas possible c'est pas toi
et là ben il coupait net parce que je
voulais pas admettre qu'il est pouvait
être dedans en vous disant ça peut-être
qu'il a essayé de vous
dire quelque chose et j'ai pas voulu le
comprendre enfin je l'ai pas compris du
tout
de suite vous éludiez le la question et
je crois que Martine secrètement
tellement espéré que ce soit pas lui que
quand elle se rend compte que c'est lui
c'est vraiment l'effondrement et au
procès simplement c'est que Jonathan va
tout dire on va rentrer dans la chose
criminelle Martinez là elle entend elle
écoute c'est terminé c'est bien son fils
qui est un meurtrier quelles sont vos
rapports avec lui aujourd'hui
ben ça va très bien on a retrouvé un peu
pour se parler puis notre complicité
vous le voyez régulièrement
tous les 15 jours
pour vous
impression vous dites que Jonathan c'est
quelqu'un de bien ça reste votre fils
mon fils c'était quelqu'un de bien avant
il a fait avant la connerie voilà et il
redevient quelqu'un de bien bon il est
enfermé il est en prison mais il reste
toujours quelqu'un de bien rien ne dit
que il pourrait refaire ça un jour
un fils les enfants restent des enfants
peut pas pas parce qu'il est passé
meurtrier qu'il faut pu aimer son enfant
on peut pas le laisser tomber non plus
il faut être présent
moi j'ai besoin de lui comme lui il a
besoin de moi
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit les parents
d'Alexia après ils ont pas
parlés
on était proche on se voyait oui sans
plus les relations étaient cordiales
non jamais non une fois qu'il est qu'il
a été incarcéré on n'avait plus jamais
reparlé
si une ou deux fois mais
c'est trop dur et ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce que tu as fait qu'est-ce qui
t'a pris
c'est trop dur
dans une interview vous avez déclaré
vous n'étiez pas inquiète pour votre
fils et qui sont dans des très bien avec
Guy Georges et l'un des tueurs en série
les plus connus de France purgent peine
un perpétuité depuis 2001 après avoir
reconnu après avoir été reconnu coupable
de cette meurtre monsieur Guy Georges
bon il a fait ce qu'il a fait il était
jugé donc moi déjà ça nous concerne pas
et mais il vient nous dire bonjour donc
on lui répond bonjour aussi ils sont ils
se parlent avec Jonathan il se côtoient
là-bas en prison peuvent faire grand
chose d'autre on va pas condamner
systématiquement une personne parce
qu'elle a déjà été condamnée Guy George
il est à sa place et personne ne dit que
il a rien fait personne ne dit qu'il a
dû aider mal jugé on dit simplement
qu'effectivement quand vous croisez Guy
Georges dans son centre de détention qui
vous dit bonjour vous lui répondez
bonjour là-dessus il y a des gens qui
vous critiquent qui disent pourquoi
aller faire de l'argent sur une affaire
pareille et sur un drame pari plana mais
pour ce qui est de l'argent c'est du 1 6
déjà on sait que enfin peut-être les
gens savent pas le grand public mais ne
devient pas milliardaire en faisant des
livres sinon ça serait mais aussi
Martine ne voulait rien du tout j'ai dû
insister comme une malade pour qu'elle
touche un petit pourcentage sur les
droits d'auteur vous tenez le coup
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que il faut
aller de l'avant
[Musique]
mais moi j'ai pas j'ai pas honte il a
fait ça j'aime pas avoir honte donc ils
vous ont tourné le dos non pas du tout
non pas du tout
[Musique]
va être dur sans toi parce que je ramène
la petite à la Maison
de la Star Academy et c'est la fin de
l'aventure
pour Julien et Stanislas Julien voilà je
me suis retrouvé en lui ça va mon juju
ça va et toi nickel tu es content d'être
sorti ou pas ça fait du bien de
retrouver la vie normale c'est rigolo tu
regrettes d'avoir participé ou tu étais
content ah pas du tout je regarde
absolument rien c'est génial bien sûr
c'est trop bien eh mais tu as fait
beaucoup parler toi tu as été sauvé
combien de fois pas depuis trois fois
deux fois deux fois
je croisais les doigts bien sûr je
voulais trop mais bon après voilà c'est
le jeu
est-ce que il y a plein de gens j'ai vu
là à chaque fois qu'il disait du piston
dans la star acte vous rien à voir pas
du tout le casting comme ça exactement
on est venu me voir sur les réseaux on
m'a dit tu veux venir je fais ok tout de
suite
il y a une séquence dans laquelle leur
t’embrouille qui a fait polémique
elle était autoritaire elle allait
jusqu'au bout quoi mais voilà je lui
envoie pas c'est pas grave tu regrette
tout ce qui s'est passé autour ou pas du
tout c'est-à-dire tout là toute la voilà
j'aime pas dire polémique mais le boss
voilà qui est ouvert
c'est un peu embêtant quoi enfin voilà
c'est ça fait jamais du bien de recevoir
du mal des gens quoi donc j'essaie
justement de déstresser les gens
c'est important de se détendre le matin
on adore ça je dors de Vannes
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci pour cette déclaration
Julien le titre de l'album
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
déjà pour ça et puis j'avais pas envie
de me péter une cheville de par la suite
parce que j'avais un problème assuré
tout simplement comme vous a pas viré
parce que vous gêniez les autres et que
vous étiez la star du programme
franchement pas du tout je pense pas
j'ai eu ma place comme tout le monde
dans ce château tout le monde défendait
ce qu'ils avaient à défendre donc voilà
j'ai peut-être eu un peu plus de chance
que certains mais sinon non non je
voyais pas ça comme ça moi vraiment pas
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a eu ce que ça
s'est pécho malheureusement très très
sale rien que dalle
je te jure c'est vrai rien rien même pas
une petite
tournement et un gardien mec non c'est
vrai bah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]